let me ask you about something that's
sort of more in the ai space that i
i think about that kind of goes along
this thread that you're
that you've spoken about about
democratizing
the technology that could destroy human
civilization
is uh from amazing work from deep mind
alpha fold to which achieved
incredible performance on the protein
folding problem single protein fold
folding problem do you think about the
use of ai
in the syn biospace of uh
i think the the gain of function
in the virus-based research that you
refer to i think
is natural mutations and sort of
aggressively mutating the virus until
you get one that like uh
that has this both contagious and
deadly but what about then using ai
to through simulation be able to compute
deadly viruses or any kind of biological
systems
is this something you're worried about
or again is this something you're more
excited about
i think computational biology is
unbelievably exciting and promising
field
and i think when you're doing things in
silico as opposed to in vivo
um you know that the dangers plummet
you don't have a critter that can leak
from a leaky lab
yes so i don't see any problem with that
except
um i do worry about the data security
dimension of it
because if you were doing really really
interesting and silico gain of function
research
and you hit upon you know through a
level sophistication we don't currently
have but you know
synthetic biology is an exponential
technology so capabilities that are
utterly out of reach today will be
attainable in five or six years
um i think if you conjured up
worst-case genomes of viruses that
don't exist in vivo anywhere they're
just in they're just in the computer
space but like
hey guys this is the genetic sequence
that would end the world let's say
um then you have to worry about the
utter hackability of every computer
network we can imagine
i mean data leaks um from the least
likely places
on the grandest possible scales have
happened and continue to happen and will
probably always continue to happen and
so that would be the danger of doing the
work in silico
um if you end up with a list of like boy
these are things we never want to see
that list leaks and after the passage of
some time certainly couldn't be done
today but after the passage of some time
um lots and lots of people in academic
labs going all the way down to the high
school level
are in a position to you know to make it
overly simplistic
hit print on a genome and have the virus
bearing that genome pop out on the other
end then you got something to worry
about
but in general computational biology i
think is incredibly important
particularly because
the crushing majority of work that
people are doing with the protein
folding problem and other things
are about creating therapeutics about
creating things
that will help us you know live better
live longer thrive be
more well and so forth and the protein
folding problem is a
monstrous computational challenge that
we seem to make
just the most glacial project on i'm
sorry progress on for years and years
but i think there's like a there's a
bi-annual competition i think
uh for for at which people tackle the
protein folding uh problem
and um deep minds entrant uh both two
years ago
like in 2018 and 2020 ruled the field
and so you know protein folding is an
unbelievably important thing if you want
to start thinking about
therapeutics because you know it's the
folding of the protein that tells us
where the
where the channels and the receptors and
everything else are on that protein
and it's from that precise model if we
can get to a precise model
that you can start barraging it again in
silicon
with you know thousands tens of
thousands millions of potential
therapeutics and see
what resolves the problems the
shortcomings that a you know about
a misshapen uh pro protein for instance
somebody with
cystic fibrosis how might we treat that
so i see nothing but good in that
you